(bright music)
(house cracks)
- Casita?
(house rumbles)
What's going on?
(bird screeches)
- The magic is in danger.
We gotta get out of here!
- We must protect our home.
We must protect our family.
(bright music)
- [Jared] So, "Encanto"
is an animated musical
set in Colombia
and it's about this amazing family.
All of them have these
wonderful, magical gifts,
with the exception of the
youngest granddaughter, Mirabel,
and the story is about her
learning to see herself
and her family different.
- Hello everybody, I'm Byron Howard,
one of the directors of "Encanto"
which we'll be talking about today.
- And I'm Jared Bush,
another director of
"Encanto" and co-writer.
And today we're gonna be looking at a clip
towards the end of the film,
which is Mirabel at her lowest moment
where for the first time
she starts to understand her
grandmother, Abuela Alma,
a little differently
and learns to understand the
choices that she has made
over the course of her life.
(Mirabel crying)
All right, so here we're with Mirabel
and what's pretty much her lowest moment.
The house has just fallen.
It was really important to us
that Mirabel blamed herself
for everything that's just happened.
To have Mirabel take it so hard
to really see that as
her singular failure,
we don't know how we're going
to ever come back from it.
So when Abuela Alma steps in here
she immediately assumes
that Abuela Alma is there
to reprimand or to scold her.
- I'm sorry.
I didn't wanna hurt us.
I just wanted to...
To be something I'm not.
- This sequence was a combination
of many different people, myself included,
drawing many, many different
versions of this moment,
and I think we all
really in the story rooms
we all get in the same page emotionally,
like we all kind of
know what the target is.
And we had talked about
this scene for years
during the development of "Encanto"
because it was really
the most critical moment
between these two women.
- I've never been able to come back here.
This river
is where we were given our miracle.
- Knowing that it's a musical
we spent a lot of time in this moment
with what should it sound like.
We dropped out the music completely,
even the environment sounds are low,
muted colors, we looked at even
like the speed of the river.
We really wanted things to feel very still
and honestly for there to be
a little bit of discomfort
in how bald and how naked this moment is.
- Where Abuelo Pedro...
- I thought we would
have a different life.
I thought I would be a different woman.
- We rarely ask voice actors
to put on a funny voice,
we really want people
to be those characters
and to really relate to those characters,
and for Maria Cecilia
Botero she's Colombian
so she knows what this moment is saying.
She knows about the resilience
and the pain and the strength
that this moment requires
and what her own grandmother
and grandfather went through.
♪ Dos oruguitas ♪
♪ Enamoradas ♪
- As the non-songwriters you go like,
this feels like it could be
a musical moment, you know,
something we always talk about is,
why does there have to be a song there?
Usually it's because
there's something very
emotional that's happening,
that a character can't
just say those things,
they must be compelled
to sing those things.
Once we had the sense of like
maybe this is a song that
a character is not singing,
we're hearing it,
it is that sort of,
it sounds like an old folk song
or it might sound like this is a song
that the spirit of Abuelo Pedro
is somehow singing a little bit
started to make a lot of sense to us.
♪ Siguen andando ♪
♪ Y navegando un mundo ♪
♪ Que cambia y sigue ♪
- [Byron] The wonderful thing
that happens during this song
is that it's all visual,
it has a beautiful love
story of this young couple
who had all the hope in the world
and things went very, very differently
than they had expected.
The research that our
teams did on materials,
like every loop of that embroidery
and the fabric on the bed is
so beautifully researched,
every tile is painted some of it by hand.
So it's really these movies are handmade.
♪ El tiempo sigue cambiando ♪
♪ Inseparables son ♪
- [Jared] It was really
critical for us to show
the youth of these characters
before what we're seeing now
which is the tragedy of their history
starting to come into play,
bringing in some of
the history of violence
that many people in Colombia had faced,
and that was very critical to them
to make sure that that
was included in the story.
There's an amazing amount of dissonance.
The song is telling you
that it's not going in a great direction
but you're seeing something wonderful
and that tells you like, uh-oh,
I'm starting to not feel good.
And then you're seeing
things get worse and worse
and then extremely tragic
as you're still hearing a love song.
That combination was something
that I think really was the efforts
of every department
firing on all cylinders,
at their very best to deliver something
that is greater than the sum of its parts.
♪ Aparte y volver ♪
♪ Hacia adelante seguiras ♪
♪ Vienen milagros ♪
♪ Vienen crisalidas ♪
♪ Hay que partir y
construir su propio futuro ♪
- When the miracle happened,
Byron boarded this,
the candle itself sort of exploded
with a butterfly of flame
came out of the candle
and it was this enormous
eight-foot-wide butterfly
that used its wings to
blow back the assailants
that were coming on their horses,
and it was this really spectacular thing
that was in our film for quite a long time
'cause it was so beautiful.
Ultimately it felt like, okay, well,
that's a wonderful moment
but we needed to simplify it.
The neat thing was
we then had this butterfly imagery
that was already in our heads,
so as Lin went to write this song
in his mind he had the
greatest miracle of nature,
which is that transformation
from caterpillar to butterfly.
Sometimes these pieces come in and out
but they can inform you in a
way that leads you down a path
that you never could have gotten to
had you not done the early work,
even though that early work changes.
- [Byron] Alma decides
that she has to leave
this pain behind
and push it down and become someone else,
and this is I think Mirabel
actually seeing that
and her grandmother
and seeing her journey.
- [Jared] It's a fantasy
space and we do play a lot
with staying true to
emotionally what's going on,
but, you know, it is a
bit of a risk, right?
We're changing the
dimensions of the house,
that's kind of weird,
the doors are not in the
order that you've seen them in
throughout the course of the movie,
but emotionally it felt right.
But those are risks you take
hoping that the audience will
go with you on that journey.
And then you're also watching her age
and we didn't want her age to feel extreme
and yet we wanted this all
to feel very lyrical and soft
as you're watching it
so that you're just really
tracking the emotion
through all this
leading to this moment where
she gets to young Mirabel
and the moment where
she didn't get a gift,
and this is the first
time we see this reaction
from Abuela Alma where she's realizing
how she let Mirabel down,
how she should have been
there to comfort her
and how she really lost her way.
(wings flapping softly)
(gentle music)
- Abuela.
I can finally see.
- [Byron] So coming out of the song
we talked a lot about what
Mirabel is feeling in that moment
and what she would say,
and I love that it's sort of wordless,
I don't think she knows what
to say to her grandmother.
- [Jared] And I love this
part so, so much, you know?
I think this is an area where
we start to lean into Germaine
Franco's beautiful score
where you're hearing the "Encanto" theme,
the theme of the miracle,
and it's the miracle
thing that's happening
as Mirabel is reacting with empathy
and she's seeing her
grandmother for the first time.
- I love how beautifully
subtle the acting is
and even the tiny little things
like how much the tears are
showing up in their eyes,
'cause it's easy to go too far.
But I just think when I saw this coming in
and it was being animated,
I believe in these people,
I believe that we're watching
real people with real souls
and it's such a magnificent
emotional moment.
- I think Andrew Ford
animated this moment,
if I'm not mistaken.
He animated both sides of both characters
having this conversation
and didn't worry about
camera placement yet.
So often in animation
you're with the character that's speaking,
but we wanted to be with the
character that was feeling
and to see that emotion hitting her face,
and so after we actually
had the performance
then we chose who to be on
camera for what part of that.
We knew we were driving to this moment,
we knew that the sun was gonna come out,
they would be in the middle of this river,
and that they would be
surrounded by butterflies.
And we spent a ton of time figuring out
how many butterflies did we need,
and we kept on adding
literally hundreds more
and hundreds more,
and what are they doing and
what's the murmuration look like
and does it head back,
does it not head back?
But I think I remember
every single time we saw it
we were like, "Double the butterflies."
And then we saw it again and we were like,
"This is way too many,"
then we're like, "No, double it again."
- It's not just an effect to
put butterflies in the air
but to kind of how do you support that
and make it feel like
this extraordinary moment.
- It's also in the middle
of the Cano Cristales
which is this amazing
real river in Colombia.
That is literally what it looks like.
You went there, that is exactly right.
And that's something that
I think a lot of people
from Colombia who know it were like,
"I know exactly what that is."
And hopefully people that watch the movie
want to then go experience
that for themselves,
discovering that this thing
that looks so fantastical
is a real place.
- I've seen this scene
for more than two years
and I still get emotional watching it.
I think that everyone
who touched this scene
did such an amazing job
and I think brought
their own emotion to it,
so it's a huge compliment
to our filmmaking team
and it's just a wonderful song too,
I just absolutely love this song.
- For me, I have a really
hard time separating
that journey of creating it
and the journey of Mirabel and Abuela Alma
who emotionally are coming together.
I don't know that I'll
ever be able to separate it
but I do love seeing people
that have watched this
and it's emotional to a lot of people
'cause I think it really
resonates for them as well.
(bright music)